my first question would be for you
Michael I want to ask you when this
story start interesting you kind of the
genesis of black hats rating the jesters
was twofold one I was interested in
doing something in Asia but the real
genesis is when went to Washington and
started talking to folks there about
about cyber intrusions and cyber theft
and what was happening in the world and
it was kind of an eye-opening experience
that the way we live our life is the way
we think our life's are the way we live
our life is not really the way they are
anymore that we're poorest and we're
vulnerable to intrusions from everywhere
and we just don't know it it's kind of
like we're no house without you know
doors and windows in the dangerous
neighborhood and we don't know it and
the extent of it was it was widespread
and it was a hot-button issue in
Washington a couple years ago two three
years ago we came back to Los Angeles
and started talking about it and people
didn't know what we're talking about so
um but that's kind of where it began and
then from there it went right to okay
who's the guy who's the main character
and what and to try and learn everything
there is to know about blackhat hackers
what motivates them what exulted
experience is and you just got done
talking to two guys who were quite
extraordinary that gave you some kind of
a sense of that a question for all of
you really what appealed to you about
this project as actors that made you
want to be a part of it I'll start with
you Chris Michael did you know it's
Michael's were my favorite filmmakers
and grown up watching his films and and
so even before I'd read the script I was
pretty much diving into the thing but
then read the script and it was a
subject that I certainly hadn't been
involved in non screen but my life had
you know was something was fairly new to
me you know I was pretty limited in my
digital cyber involvement and and it
fascinated me now as Michael said it was
something that a couple of years ago
when we were researching the film
did exist all the things are in the news
now but you know Watson has public and
and you know the idea that we as
vulnerable as you say and as the film
talks about was something that I wanted
to learn more about and jumper you know
jump into that opportunity I can only
repeat what Chris said I wanted to work
with Michael Mann I did I want to work
with him I wanted to be a part of
anything that he was directing I think
that you always want to gravitate
towards people who absolutely are great
at what they do and go for authenticity
and cyberterrorism was a subject matter
that fascinated me also I mean listen I
remember playing an FBI agent many moons
ago and I sat with some FBI agents and
they said cyber terrorism was more
potent than actual you know terrorist
attacks and I thought to myself wow and
it was something I wanted to learn more
about so and exotic locations did appeal
to me also and tongue way could you talk
about why you want it to be in the movie
what excited you about this opportunity
everybody sitting here is some more than
more than the reason and more in some
words I can say everybody here of course
and also I never do this kind of part
and usually I work in the art movie very
dramatic you know the feminine but this
time it's the first time I do a very
independent spirit and I was so very
tough and computer engineer on computer
expert that's very interesting so I want
to try and yeah very good experience
with this great family one do you have I
just have to echo what everyone else has
said about Michael Mann being one of
their
greatest directors ever and to be able
to work with him to get the call from a
casting director saying that there's a
role for an Asian male who speaks
English with an American accent as I is
this is this for real as this a prank
this is a prank call and there's a
knowledge and it's a really meaty role
and I'm like okay you know tell me how
to audition tell me how to sign up and
that was the beginning of an incredible
life-changing experience we just spoke
with the cyber experts a few minutes ago
and I'm just wondering because we
understand you had a chance to speak to
some of them prior to production and
everything have each of you gone and
changed your passwords made them more
complicated and you know what did you
learn from them and you know is there is
is there something that you could use in
your own personal life that you you
picked up from these guys the first
thing is they were with us you know we
you know we do a kind of immersive
preparation to get into character and
that starts many many many months before
we start shooting so whether it's
learning coding or or you know or you
know viola learning she visited Michelle
Leonardi a learning women in law
enforcement and attitudes you mean you
you pick up how somebody thinks how what
their attitudes are what their
background is how they walk how they
talk how they drink a cup of coffee it's
so rich you know so it's always a great
idea to you know my point of view to
work with the actors who will turn on is
all these folks are by that same thing
of that kind of immersive research and
from these guys specifically it was
coding from fennec oh it was different
kinds of of hacking from Chris
McCandless but time was Chris so Chris
could you know right what code Polson
had experiences of black hat hacker and
that's you know how we home and Chris
and tang way all interacted
you know with these folks we heard in
Washington after you know two years ago
that I said am I being paranoid and not
wanting to take a laptop to where we
were going to look for locations and
they said none of us ever take our
laptops to where we go look for
locations so people who've been to know
I understood the threat from what time
yeah I'm you know as Michael said about
learning how to write code and
understanding the brain of the computer
and all that which was new to me I
remembered asking one of the guys I said
knowing what you know because it became
evident pretty quick that that we knew
nothing of the majority of us knew
nothing and compared to what these guys
knew and I said knowing what you know
you know you exist behind the curtain so
to speak and you see behind the curtain
do you look at the world differently do
you know I do do do you have an upper
hand and he just started laughing he
said man people have no idea how exposed
they are invulnerable and what's
possible and and that's it that's the
power now this is the Brian it's you
know not just in the criminal world but
anywhere is is is that that they're the
guys that the superheroes you know and
and that sort of highly intelligent you
know alien type advancement that these
guys send the you know they have within
themselves was something and every day
impressed me and a lot of different
things I did pick up you know just that
I'm a sitting duck no seriously I mean I
I could say more but I I'm a sitting
duck because I can't get ahead of them
they're far ahead of me I mean um yeah
that's that's what I learned how
vulnerable we are you know it's a big
silent monster out there that's what it
feels like yeah
another question over there yes first of
all congratulations to all of you on a
terrific film I really enjoyed it and
for mr. Mann I want to ask you why were
these these the best actors to tell your
story why do i why were these the best
actors to tell your story
that becomes individual destroy some of
each of each individual's the casting
process and lots of times you know you
you know when you know I conceived of
Hathaway as a a guy from the
working-class neighborhood in the south
side of Chicago whose father was a steel
worker because I knew people like that
and in the 70s particularly bandits
illowsky was a very progressive labor
leader in Chicago and you know and there
was just a quality of a certain very
bright very direct very centered and you
know sitting with Kristen Costa Rica and
we were just talking and talking and he
didn't know this but I'm thinking this
is the guy this is the guy you know and
it has to do with natively who you know
Chris is plus Chris's you know you know
enthusiasm for the kind of immersive
immersion in a character that then took
us to Stateville prison and you know and
blast furnaces at US Steel at 4:00 in
the morning and and his willingness to
kind of lose himself into the moment
which were all directors look at and you
know Lee Hom Tang Wei you know Lee Hom
is brilliant and he's a great musician
and there's this precision and an
intellect and he just you know is he
just fits exactly who I had in mind for
Chen and Tang Wei within five minutes of
meeting her in Hong Kong I knew that she
was Lian and I was asking myself you
know do I want to let her on that
everybody just made the decision because
she's very close to Hua Lian is as a
character
there are very few women programmers in
China and there are even fewer network
engineers and so it kind of be speaks to
certain independence and strong
visuality and that's who Tang Wei is
viola goes without saying I mean jealous
is a great great great actress and I was
very fortunate to work with her but
these are all individual casting
decisions you make you make them on
every picture 2009 was your last film so
we kind of missed you on the big screen
we missed you on the big screen your
last film was in 2009 with Public
Enemies so wondering if you had taken a
break or this is a project you've been
working on for a couple years so if I
did after
Public Enemies who did luck for almost
two years and then from luck I started
working on three screenplays which this
is one we were in Washington with our
when the story really occurred you know
to us on August 8th 2011 so the
monotonous four three half years for the
actors what's your favorite Michael Mann
movie and Tom way so tell me I
understand this is your first action and
a straight learn movies so I was
wondering which one is the challenge is
the language that you have to say a lot
of English dialogue or it's actually the
physical and travelling to shoot the
film and Lee Hom my question is so
congratulations for the daughter and
right now you're married man and the
father I was honoring will you do more
films in Hollywood in the future or
maybe still focused on your music career
definitely of course that's not my
mother tongue even just like Cantonese I
speak very fluent Cantonese but when I'm
doing a movie in Cantonese I'll soon
have prominent yeah English I think I
love language
I love learn languages like actually
actually computer code it's another
language as well and so on so that's why
I really curious to join this movie what
I can learn and yeah through the movie I
think more more about is how how great
to the experience to work with Michael
and Chris and Lee Hong and viola so
language we're getting the second thing
so the experience work with them such a
amazing team is more important and I got
a lot and about a travel Trevor I would
say I travel quite a lot I'm very used
to it like on flight around the earth
for it's very used to I think we all or
we all similar yeah thank you music and
movies are both so important to me and
you know I started off as a musician and
I'm doing more movies now but now I
haven't haven't given up the music
either and I also should add that
Michaels and is an amazing musical I
feel like every everyday that we're on
set and we're improvising it's like a
jazz session and we're moving the camera
around and changing lines and doing
things differently and it's like you
know he's getting these really real
reactions out of it and you just kind of
like have to have faith in the whole
process and let go and I was telling
Michael the other day like act 3 felt
like Ravel's Bolero and I was like so it
was it was this magnum opus it's like a
symphony if you listen to the music and
black hat and and how the music drives
the movie especially in act 3 I think
it's really something special coming
from my background it really stood out
to me then when we're recording ADR of
those
you know what that is additional
dialogue recording that you're doing
post and we home put something down we
said well great this would be great but
we just have to split the word and when
and while the dialogue editor was
struggling with the Pro Tools lean home
kind of took over the Pro Tools and he
did all the editing himself so mr. man
for you you've directed some of the in
my opinion the greatest crime dramas the
last 30 years entering the world of
cybercrime with this film did you talk
about how you were able to marry your
style of storytelling and shooting with
the world of cybercrime and really
create a new genre of the cybercrime
genre film yeah thank you very much if
we all were successful in doing that
that would be great you know first of
all yes it's the beginning what you know
what kind of motivated you to do this is
what was the beginning you know first of
all it it takes place in our world as it
is right now
right and the cutting edge of this
moment and you know everything the
interconnectedness of all things
everything interconnected with
everything else that's the world we live
in now it's never going to go back to
being the way it used to be and you have
a convicted black hat hacker who's a
conditional release from federal prison
to pursue a cyber criminal adversary a
guy whose high speed dangerous
world-class he's a ghost he's out there
somewhere they don't know who he is
where he is why he's doing what he's
doing and so doing half the way it's
trying to outrun his past and you know
take control of a future that he may
have he may not have it's agented by his
pal we went to MIT with who could not
have come from a different world and and
that and Schenn sister who's a network
engineer you know candid and spontaneous
and and and you
with Barrett who engineered this and
then feels like she's being played and
it sets up a conflict among this group
which then resolves itself into them
being very unified and they move forward
in what's really kind of a detective
story but the thrill in making it was
that the tropes of the part the
mechanics of the storytelling it was an
opportunity to also pull them out of the
very current world we live in right now
so rather than something you might have
done 20 years ago when they're trying to
find out the location of where guy may
be where you might interrogate an
informant instead of that you know
Barrett in hems and at Hathaway
con a guy in the NSA to download a
password down down the password and he's
downloading a PDF Hathaway he's able to
get in download some software restore
some code from the Chowan reactor and
what does he get he gets a location
still don't know who the guy is where he
is what he's doing but they know that
this guy's command and control server is
in Jakarta Indonesia you know that's a
clue so the storytelling itself was also
we were able to take it I find that very
exciting to be able to pull that
together you know where you tell the
storytelling itself is taken from that
same world of you know the immediate
right now is it were Chris you're a part
of a long-term project where you have to
keep your body in great physical shape
did that inform Hathaways philosophy of
training his body as well as his mind in
prison and also how did you come to the
voice of Hathaway I mean the training
for this was you know I was once I'm
done with Thor when I get rid of that
bulk and that size because that's just
sort of screamed to that character and
so but I wanted to my training instead
of just running on the treadmill and
trying to get rid of the way mainly
built in some sort of martial arts and I
boxed a lot in the past and done lot of
muy Thai and you mean Michael talked
about you know the time he'd spent in
prison you know you go in one person and
come out another and through those
experience he was gonna be able to
physically be able to handle himself and
that was whether that was from his kind
of background he'd grown up in or not
but certainly what his experiences were
in prison but the the voice we spent a
number of you know days in Chicago and
there were endless kind of conversations
between Michael and I and and and work
my dialect coaches and and and it became
more an attitude I think then than
anything else you know there was the you
know the the structural sound to it and
phonetics and what-have-you but the way
this guy spoke and the rhythm to his
speak you know we'd picked up things
from friends and Michael's in Chicago
also we went to certain prisons and
spoke with people the way guys in prison
speak and there's a rhythm and a bounce
and and that indicated it but you know
Michael was I mean I had dialect cutters
but Michael was my kind of guide you
know he was from the place and knew what
he was after
Travie talking about how authentic and
how that wasn't so important to you that
this was really authentic and it's true
this is now but I also wanted to say
that film is visually authentic it's
stunning and you actually went to these
countries and shot in over 70 locations
can you talk about that experience as a
filmmaker as an actors and shooting all
these locations and in all these
countries well you you try to find
places that I mean first of all it may
we're some visual medium you know it's a
kind of interweaving of tax music
visuals the story dialogue people and
you know you want places to feel
evocative of what the scenes about
that's where it begins so if it's tense
you don't want to be in a room like this
if there's tension you want to be a room
that has a very low ceiling and you try
to come
they these things that we all as the
audience feel and a59 Asian is a very
exciting place to go and the the I mean
the ultimate thing is that you know is
is that you know location that makes the
scene come to life if I if we make if we
can make the scene comes alive then it
comes alive for all of us for the actors
walking in the room they look out the
window of like the Hong Kong safehouse
and they see all this life on Kowloon
it's really there it's not digitally put
in and we're not looking at a green
screen where some the gaffers put up a
piece of tape and said you see that
piece of tape that's not really a piece
of tape that's the rest of the street
this is the real thing we're really
there you're really seeing that out the
window and you walk and you walk to work
and you walk up the narrow staircase and
all the smells and everything else and
that's really the place so that because
we're all real complex organisms will
all perceptually way more brilliant than
we even know we are we take everything
in and alleys great actors take all of
that in and they really feel they're
walking on wooseok street in kowloon to
their safe house because they're walking
on woosh long string and column to this
safe house so that's that those are the
kind of decisions for the end of the
film it became what's the most alien
landscape these two fugitives who are
very much underdogs of being hunted but
nevertheless are hunting with improvised
weapons and everything else what's the
most alien landscape I could imagine and
put them in and that became you know
Jakarta in it that parade that ceremony
any of you want to comment on that on
traveling and working all these
countries one of the great things that I
learned from Michael Mann about location
scouting was the best way to do it as a
helicopter that's something he told me
exactly him you gotta know and that way
through everyone I do location scouting
go up in a helicopter
he's been so many days up in a
helicopter in every single city and then
when he'd see something that that struck
is fancy yeah he'd go check it out and
so that's why there's so many really
really cool occasion I mean I've been to
Malaysia
so many times over the last 20 years
Hong Kong but the places he found I was
like how did you find this place about
thirty of them you know we you could
shoot in the back lot of Li somewhere in
parking lot and mock it up and or a
green screen we so had plenty of over
the years but you have a visceral
physical response to being in those
places and the sights and sounds and the
smells just bring something else out in
you and you're not having to fake that
or imagine that it sits there and you it
it becomes as much an actor something
you bounce off as the other people
you're working with you know so that was
it was a such a treat to work in those
places which you know well loud and
noisy and I remember a lot of the time
the sound guys worrying about we can't
shoot this we're counting there's too
much noise and Michael said no no I just
keep going this is great and so it has
it sounds unlike anything else you know
it looks like anything unlike anything
else and and I wish you could always
shoot like that you know and it was
described well I I've never been to that
part of the world I absolutely I loved
it and you know the location is another
character it really is
it can't be recreated on the soundstage
yeah you can imagine it but I'd rather
not but um the heat Kowloon the noise
everything was just different it just
was a different world that I know for
myself as imaginative as I feel I am I
would not have been able to go there I
had to be there and that safe house
it was just closed in space and being
with all these people and the sounds and
the life going on out
hide and it was it was pretty
extraordinary it's like I said it's a
character in and of itself yeah oh and
Leon said I had a copter remember when I
was saying Singapore I was sitting in
the room and a waitin and then I see a
helicopter and heard about my co is
going to do some like searching some
location or something and then I just
passed and then after after a while
passed again passed again how many
circles yeah just I see you on time and
also yeah for me as well the the the
little plane I how to say they're
praying with Chris we were in oh yeah I
mean the qinger you're in Hong Kong yeah
I mean the plane yeah yeah yeah I just
Wow when we were in the sky for probably
more than half hour and asking where's
my college there still haven't lived the
ground we were they were they were in a
king air flying or flying out of haunt
and it seemed where they're flying out
of Hong Kong and we were in a helicopter
shooting it yeah we shot it lots and
lots actually all of our bad from the
plane in the plane up there flying by oh
we almost got the same shake yeah we're
doing laughs and I remember I was saying
cuz I passed that several times of my my
heart is in my office
not my office my company office is in
come John so and then I finally I think
I started sending message hey can you
see the plane they said no okay wait we
will pass again yeah something like and
also probably this is the first movie I
work and there's no all real set because
all the other movies I work with some
studio awesome
thing the fake how to so fix that
bulging how to say that yeah so that's
really really nice and it's really
important for for me to believe it just
like what your factors yeah so so nice I
wish every movie I can do like this I
just wanted to congratulate you and
thank you so much for being here today
Michael is there anything else you
wanted to say right guys miss is there
any more way more time for last question
for many guys right our relations with
China are fascinating balance where
we're adversary with them and in some
areas you know naval presence cyber
intrusion were very close partners in
trade and Finance and it's it's a
balance between these two kind of sets
of relationships we have that are that
are maintained where they're China's
biggest trading partner they're ours so
it's very interesting one thing that's
interesting is one the Obama
administration asked China for help with
North Korea on the recent attack you
know it's kind of something that we
thought you know way back when you know
if there was a common interest or
something in parallel that you know they
would work together that was the basis
of it of why there we have this kind of
American Chinese informal Asian group
I didn't understand a thing you should
say no thing with the uniform yeah they
were they were they were authentic
everything you see in the movies is
authentic basically even the code that
you see on on screens when we're
programming and I just want to comment
on this gentleman's question about yes
it was extremely refreshing to be able
to play a a white hat hacker and you
know in in the world of of cyber there's
the black cats who are who are like the
cowboys you know back in the Wild West
the black hats are the bad guys on the
white hats are the good guys and Chris
and I are white hat hackers and we're
trying to find the black hat and you
know it was it was great now most people
were assuming all your Chinese guy in
the Michael Mann film playing planet
yeah playing with it with Chris
Hemsworth so like are you the villain
well thank you so much and Congrats
you